make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking back up again with
Shazam part 5 this one's really really
cool because what it does is explains
the nature behind the wildlands right
like how everything sort of popped off
and unfolded and then it also gives us a
little bit more of the game lands which
I'm really excited about and so so in
this in the last video we basically
picked up with like black Adam
essentially like arriving kind of
returning and then showing up to the
rocket eternity and realizing that like
the doors to all the magic lands except
for them the monster land had basically
been open now the dark lands we have not
seen yet and so you know when it comes
to like the the was wasn't lands we
haven't really seen those either we've
only seen the fun lands a game lands and
of course you have the the earth land
itself and then the wild lands and
that's basically been it but the
indication here from from Black Adam is
that one if the monster lands were open
then who knows what would happen it
would just it would be a terrible
situation and two if all the lands were
to go to war with each other then it
would basically spell out end of the
universe and and it would doom all of
reality now you know if I'm kind of
being honest here this kind of seems to
be a non running thing of what's going
on with with DC at the moment I don't
know if it's really their intention but
it seems like every story that's going
on kind of deals with this idea that
like and if they win the world will and
like all of reality will end and the
issue with that is it kind of starts to
get thin right I mean it's like the it's
like the idea of Superman dying right
like Superman died and suddenly nobody
could die in comics right because
Superman came back so anybody could come
back it was a license to kill death in
comic books it's one of these things
where kind of loses effect right like a
reality destroying event needs to be
something that's like huge and massive
like holy cow this will end all things
now I think that that really like Scott
Snyder's Justice League kind of takes
the lion's share of that in terms of
things popping off but it is kind of
interesting to see in this because it's
like how can a bunch of anthropomorphic
animals and a bunch of gamers lead to
the end of all reality and not to guess
we're really where like the other realms
begin to come into play we just haven't
really seen those yet I mean it could be
like the powers and the things there are
just wild and exotic and so it's a cool
little moment here because what this
does is initially shift over to Shazam
now with Shazam dealing with king kid
trying to a very least rescue Mary
Marvel it's one of these things where he
kind of hits the nail on the head
right but unintentionally but it also
sort of hits at the role of Shazam as a
superhero because one of the things that
Black Adam always hated about Billy
Batson having the living Lightning and
being like
the newest avatar basically of the old
wizard Shazam is that Billy was sort of
deemed to be more worthy than Black Adam
was but the problem is that Billy is for
the most part kind of a terrible
superhero right I mean like he's a
little kid he goes around and does kid
things he loses track of what he's
supposed to be doing he loses focus on
the bigger picture whereas black Adam is
a lot more serious I mean if I think
like I don't actually be a better
superhero than Shazam would but it is
kind of cool to see that play out now
the reality is that this focuses on one
element of the picture if you look at
Shazam in a broader scope right now you
kind of move away from this particular
story this instance as he's viewed but
like Adam and you look at him as the
hero that he's been over the course of
DC Comics well then it becomes a lot
more interesting and he becomes a lot
more clear in terms of why he was pegged
to be that character but again I kind of
sit with my statement will probably piss
off the Shazam fans but in this day and
age you can't say anything without
pissing people off so I'm not too
worried about it but but I would say
black Adam would probably be a better
superhero than Shazam would I mean I
really think he would he'd be be far
more intense and I think he'd be a
little more cruel in terms of his goals
but at the end of the day wars are won
by those who are willing to do what the
bad guys will do not those who were
trying to take the higher higher step
right because I mean when it when it
comes to conflicts like that it's always
kind of the dichotomy between the good
guy the bad guy is until the good guy is
willing to do what the bad guy will do
in order to win then ultimately the bad
guy will usually come out on top in the
end run I mean the idea the the fantasy
depiction of superheroes doesn't really
work that way in like the real world you
got to be as bad as a bad guy to win
otherwise you've won you're never gonna
be taken seriously into you're never
gonna have the gumption to take the
victory at the end of the day you're
only ever going to be a half-measure and
so it's one of these these these cool
little discussions that you get you know
when it when it comes to these kind of
comics that's one of reasons why I like
them so much right I mean you know the
nice guys never win it's just the way
that it works you got to be a bad guy if
you want to win sometimes it's just kind
of how it goes and so because of that
where Shazam tries to reason with King
Kidd and say hey look like you know this
is a bad thing that kind of stuff what
ends up doing is kind of basically
toying with King kid almost kind of
building on and saying look you're
basically a kid who's afraid that's
that's essentially what this is you're a
kid who's afraid that you might get hurt
again because of the situation that you
came from but like I've bounced from
foster home to foster home I've never
really known my parents I've never
really known what it meant to be loved
by a biological parent but I've still
made do and I've still done well you
know it's kind of comparing his
situation to the situation of kinky
saying you can basically be a
functioning reasonable person to now
king kids response to this is I will let
all of you go if you give me the living
lightning if you give me your power
do not let all of you go and everything
will be fine and again that's kind of
the indication here that because of the
power of Shazam because it's so coveted
because of the fact that everybody wants
it that is one of these things where if
what like Adam says is true then this
will boil down to everybody trying to
attain the power of the living lightning
right like in the game lands it'll be
will give you the living lightning and
then you can go home you know and
whatever you know in the wild lands give
us a living lightning and you can go
home you know be one of these things
where give us your power so we can
conquer the rest of the wild land or the
rest of the the magic lands and then you
can go home but that's kind of what
Black Adam has been trying to prevent
here it's what he's been trying to
basically eliminate and so the result of
this is that is that Shazam basically
tears off the the mouthpiece of Mary
Marvel frees her she shouts to Zam and
then she becomes her superhero
counterpart and then we switch over to
the game lens now the game lands I so
say is the coolest part because it's
like ready player one but the game
inside where all you do is just run
around and play games all the time
the funny thing about this is that is
that in this instance you basically got
Eugene who's just kinda like hey look so
like I just want to play games that's
like that's really all I want to do is
just play a whole bunch of games if
getting to the CPU is what we need to do
in order to to get back home well then I
can get us there right because your
genes the gamer of the Shazam family he
just plays video games all the time
mister he's like the best person suited
to get them out of there the problem
with this is that he makes a deal to get
10,000 credits and then he wants to he
wants to like jump into this race that
can let them beat the game master and
that's when it's basically at least uh
you know take part in this particular
race to build up more credits and that's
what he's told no no your rank is too
high now you can't compete in this but
your friend can so it's kind of like
okay well that sucks now it's kind of a
cool little moment there but at this
point then we jump back to the wildlands
and we actually pick up with the
kangaroo court now this is kind of a
double meaning right this kangaroo court
is designed to show it's a court where
you know is a kangaroo who's the
prosecutor but a kangaroo court is also
a name given to a court system where a
person's put on trial for little or no
effort with little and no evidence and
then just kind of is more like a dog and
pony show basically and so that's
essentially what's happening here
there's literally a kangaroo court but
then it also follows the meaning because
there's no real evidence against them
outside of the fact that they are human
and humans aren't really allowed there
now again because of how there
because of the fact that this entire
trial was basically a sham they're
essentially found guilty like like that
and there are sentenced to death by
Tiger uh and it gets kind of wonky
because death from that's when we
basically pick up with like how
everything unfolded and what we end up
learning over the course of this is that
we're one of the Tigers in the early
part of the story uh I guess in the last
the last issue who is essentially
arrested for reading literature like how
not to eat you know my friends and
things like that where he's arrested and
turned in we end up finding out that in
the early days of this particular
universe on this earth that humans did
run the show that humans really were
just kinda it was probably in a function
similar to ours albeit without any kind
of superheroes but eventually animals
rose up against it right so it's like
it's like pitas wet dream basically but
animals wrote up throws up against them
and then like turned on the humans but
during this gigantic revolt during this
massive revolt that took place what
ended up happening is that the Tigers
actually cited with humans against all
the animals and when that happened
Tigers were kind of branded as inherent
trench right like Tigers can never be
trusted they could never be considered
you know reasonable they are given a
little bit of leeway in the sense that
all animals are kind of allowed to go
out there and do their own thing
but if it tiger at any point does
anything that seems to indicate that
they could turn against other animals
they're immediately arrested and that's
basically the way it goes and that's
what happened with this guy he was
carrying literature that indicated that
he was trying to resist the temptation
to consume his friends to basically
function the way Tigers functioned
back when there were City zoos and
different things like that and the
result is that he was arrested and he
was thrown here and so he's essentially
sentenced to either consume Darla and
Freddie Freeman alongside the other
Tigers in the City Zoo or he'll be
killed stuffed and mounted so like it's
pretty dark it's pretty screwed up and
it's it's pretty twisted but it is a
cool little bit of storytelling here
because what you get at the end of all
this is that we're black Adam is racing
to the magic lands as far as fast as he
can to try to run up on on on the fun
lands where Billy Batson resides and
where all these dark secrets are being
held
he suddenly met by dr. sivana who
basically gives them kind of this
ultimatum join the army of Miz during
the Society of Mister mind or or die
it's kind of a cool thing here right
because it's almost like mr. mind is
building up his own legion of doing you
know kind of bringing back his own
society from back in the day which is
you basically hat and so with that in
mind like it's kind of a slow build here
is kind of the idea that it's like it's
taking a little while
to basically build up to the grand
pooh-bah sort of finale that we're used
to seeing with these kinds of stories
but again like we don't know exactly how
long this is gonna last for I assume six
issues it could go longer maybe seven
eight or nine issues again it's kind of
finicky when it comes to to the Shazam
run because we're not really given like
a volume right it's not like you know
part one of six or part two of eight or
something along those lines it's just
kind of a story being told though that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain it make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]